hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the Riga interzonal
Tournament of 1979. we are checking out
some games by a former world champion
Mikhail tal you guys have been
requesting some of his games and I
thought okay we've only checked out his
games when he was younger uh but let's
check out some of the games when he was
um well older olderish as this is some
20 years after the legendary 1959
candidates tournament that he won uh
where he got a chance and privilege to
challenge uh the the then world champion
Mikhail but Phoenix and he defeated him
in the World Chess Championship match so
this style has already been world
champion he already lost his wheelchair
championship title you know he's again
playing in the interzoneal tournament
trying to qualify for the uh for the
candidates tournament
um so they are looking for six more more
players two inter-zone tournaments will
be played and uh Victor Cortino and
Boris paski have already qualified for
the candidates tournament so six more
spots need to need to be filled and the
tall uh absolutely crushed this this
tournament he uh he not only did he win
first place uh he won first place ahead
of pologevsky uh with a margin of two
and a half points which is absolutely
incredible but not only that he won it
with 11 wins zero losses and six draws
the only player to go undefeated in the
entire tournament so it was uh
definitely an impeccable performance by
tal and uh uh a quote of even said that
um this was toppling the absolute best
chess that he ever played some say that
it was due to his professional uh and
personal relationship with Anatoly
karpov he was spending a lot of time
with him and now as a carpool was the
reigning world champion pal wanted to
qualify again and challenge karpov for
the title so will that happen or not I'm
sure you guys know where you uh you know
your chess history very well but I
thought we'd check out some of the games
from this tournament maybe even all of
them if they are if they are interesting
so here this is the first round game in
his face facing a very very strong
Soviet Grandmaster vitality cheskovsky
uh not not only a very strong strong
Grand Master but also uh last year's um
uh Soviet Champion or he he shared first
place with tal uh but uh I mean you can
imagine he's very very strong so let's
check it out tell has the white pieces
and he plays Ponte E4 and this is a very
very different style than uh than what
you would expect when you hear the name
tal you would expect you know pieces to
be flying everywhere you know crazy
sacrifices happening but this is a
probably like I said uh due to his um uh
spending more time with with a
positional player like Anatoly karpov uh
he developed a bit of a different style
but still if if you really dare him to
sacrifice he will so E4 we have Pawn to
C5 which of course he goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight F3 we have
knighted the C6 and now D4 so the
standard Sicilian captures captures
Knight to F6 with knights the C3 and
here uh Vitaly goes for E5 this is the
Pelican or the or the special or the
last Sicilian Knight D to B5 and now
Pawn to D6 a line that was played quite
a lot in the castle versus Carolina uh
World Choice championship match in 20
2018 in London and uh I I think five
games were played all together for In
classical time format one in in Rapid
time formatted Magnus one of course
Magnus had the black pieces um and uh it
was uh a pretty crazy lines were played
there engine lines were played so a bit
of a different than we'll see here but
let's see what happens Knight D5 Knight
captures of course Knight C7 check is
being threatened so you have to
eliminate the Knight E captures and
Knight to B8 in the match if you
remember Magnus tried both Knight B8 and
Knight to E7 so Knights the B8 and now
c4 uh caruana played Ponte a for here
here we have C4 by tal uh we have Ponte
A6 chasing away the Knight Knight C3 and
Bishop to E7 so uh pretty standard stuff
that you can see even today with Bishop
D2 Castles by both players and now uh
Ponte F5 we have Pawn to F4 and now
Bishop up to F6 very nicely placing the
bishop on this diagonal at some point E4
will probably be played Queen to C2 and
now Knight to D7 the Knight can now come
to C5 then you can imagine D3 happening
and the uh e for happening the D3 Square
will be vacated and then maybe the
Knight can uh find a nice outpost on D3
so King to H1 uh tal knows uh as every
great attacker knows that you you
absolutely must play King to H1 in the
open Sicilian we have G6 G3 and now Rook
the E8 and I'll just plays Bishop to D2
and it is now as of move 17 that this
position has never been reached again we
have B6 and Tall Place uh sorry uh B6
and towel plays Rook 8 to E1 nicely
getting the Rook into the game Bishop to
G7 and now Pawn to B3 tall really making
um uh a nice set up here for for his
Pawn structure Rook the A7 uh now now
preparing to shift the Rook over to C7
uh and then maybe maybe play B5 the
queen is still on C2 we have A4 by tall
stopping B5 and The Rook to C7 and here
we have Bishop to D1 opening up the uh e
file for the white rook and now comes
Bishop to B7 here if uh Vitali really
wanted to play E4 here was not a bad not
a bad moment to do so for example Bishop
to E3 You're Gonna Play Queen to F6 put
pressure on the Knight here and not
Knight the E to prepare in Bishop to D4
Knight to C5 you're gonna put pressure
on that um at D3 square but you never
really want to move it because uh Bishop
captures on B6 and here probably Queen
to D2 B5 can be played and now it's a
it's a very very exciting game for both
white and black let's say it captures a
captures Queen to A5 tal would attack
The Rook let's say Rook the B7 Tower
would play Knight to D4 and it's a
pretty crazy stuff now you have the the
E2 Square if Knight the D3 ever lands
you don't have to give up the exchange
but now tal also has Knight E6 Knight C6
so it would be it would be a very
interesting uh interesting game but
Vitaly knows that you you don't want to
play uh crazy chess against Tao so he
just continues development Bishop to B7
and of course the bishop does belong
here tiles King is on the same diagonal
with G4 by tal now saying what is up
with with the F5 Pawn I'm putting
pressure on it and I'm ready to capture
here and now the way to play this is e
captures on F4 but it's a very very
funky line that you guys will enjoy in
the game E4 was played uh but that's
what I meant we thought he should have
played E4 on the previous move but
Bishop to B7 followed by uh E4 after G4
was played simply does not work uh here
he should have gone for e-captures on F4
and after captors captures and Bishop
captures it looks very bad because well
what do you do about the D6 Pawn but the
thing is there's Knight to F6 and now
how do you continue this there are a
couple you can play but basically
whatever white plays let's say G
captures here you're gonna play Knight
captures on D5 and open up an attack on
the Knight here and now let's say Knight
captures on D5 You're Gonna Play Bishop
captures on D5 the C Pawn is pinned and
if now Bishop to F3 you're gonna trade
Bishop captures through captors you're
gonna capture back and if Queen captures
let's say Rook to F7 equal material both
kings are white in the open this is very
very equal equal play
uh but that's a lot of moves and that's
uh again uh going into uh crazy
territory against Tao not everyone's
Forte so here E4 was played but natal
plays G captures on F5 G captures and
Bishop to E3 now puts pressure on the B6
spawn and how do you deal with this of
course Knight the C5 you can also play
something like Rook to C8 to maybe help
out with the queen but Knight the C5 uh
defends the pawn and prepares to bring
the Knight to D3 so here toggles Rook to
G1 of course he wants to double up on
the G file and put pressure on the black
king Knight to D3 attacks the rook and
now Comes The Rook e to F1 and now Queen
to H4 uh putting putting pressure on top
King side uh maybe you you can even get
the the Rooks into the game but what
about the B6 Pawn can you just capture
this and it comes with Tempo the C7 Rook
will be hanging so while it is possible
tal ignores it he actually goes for Rook
to G3 and uh continues to double up on
the G file we have King to h8 it's
important to get the King off of the G
file so King to each it first and now
Bishop captures on B6 there was no good
way to defend the pawn so of course uh
Vitali didn't even try Rook F7 Bishop
goes back to E3 and now Rook to F6 so
now like I said it's a very different
tall game where tal even though he
wasn't actively trying to win a pawn
he's just up upon it's vitalik who's
trying to uh create some imbalances in
the position and attack dal's King so
Rook F6 preparing Rook G6 for maybe even
Rook to H6 Queen to G2 by tal now
putting pressure on the bishop and The
Rook G6 stopping that so here are tall
trades with Rook captures H captors
Queen capture so now tal grabs another
Pawn but okay Vitale can always capture
back on F4 at some point because you
know this Rook is coming to G1 so Rook
to G8 and tal goes Rook to G1 uh just
giving up the F4 Pawn so Vitality
captures that Knight captures an F4 but
now there are many ways talk could play
this he decides to go for a queen trade
he plays Queen G5 uh if uh if this was a
20 year old younger top probably we
would see something like Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Knight E2
attacking the queen and once the queen
moves something like Rook G5 going after
Checkmate or you know just trying to win
material here you would have to play
Rook Queen to F3 check Rook back to G2
and now okay the game continues it's a
very very wild position a lot of things
can happen but white is completely
winning here because there's really not
much you can do the bishop has no way of
entering the game you can never move the
The Rook from G80 because Queen
characters and G7 is just Checkmate uh
there's really nothing you can do it's
just a position where you can wait and
see how Tao will win this probably just
capturing and D6 moving the queen back
and then maybe advancing the pawn could
be a bit dangerous because it opens up
this diagonal but it is one of the one
of the options but here tall just went
for Queen to G5 he offered the queen
trade and I think avitali was happy to
accept this queen captures Rook captures
and now Bishop captures on C3 Rook
captures anjit with check King captures
and the ending with Bishop captures on
F4 so now after all is said and done
both players have a bishop pair so it's
a four Bishop end game and tal is up a
pawn it's it's a past H Pawn but Vitali
also has a past E Pawn so can he bring
his Bishops into the game like I said
said this bishop doesn't look like it's
going to be able to enter the game
because you can't move the white pawns
and you can't move your F5 Pawn as long
as this bishop is on F4 so Bishop to E5
this kind of fixes that pretty much your
only way to get the lights were Bishop
into the game but now tell just trades
Bishop capture spawn captures and King
to G2 we have King to F7 Bishop to C2
now King to F6 and now King to F2 we
have King to G5 and here top played King
to E3 and he was in this position animal
42 that Vitali joshkowski resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh there's no way to actually get
the bishop into the game there's no way
to play some moves with your king
because uh once you do that the the
pawns are just marching forward and you
will not be able to stop them you can
never play F4 check because then just
King captures and you lose even more
material so there's there's literally no
move you can play here uh and that's why
uh chakowski uh Vitali resigned so that
was the first round game uh tall tall
takes it and at some point I don't know
in which position tal actually offered
the draw uh Vitali uh declined the draw
he wanted to play for the win uh and
then it it bounced back
um uh and that I was able to to to win
and it really really uh got off to uh to
a great start for him as like I
mentioned here he won the tournament
without losing a single game so we're
gonna check out some other games uh like
I said maybe even all of them uh and
we'll see uh uh how how it came to be
that he won the tournament with such
such an incredible result and remember
this is 20 years after Taos Prime
basically after the the legendary 1959
candidates tournament uh so yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed it stay tuned for the
rest of the tournament uh I would like
to thank Ned Riley BB chess London
systemadi and the Marco still for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up any
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day